aujourd'hui les samoa noumea tuamotu les
samoa 3420 km² 14 îles dont l'ensemble
constitue l'archipel des samoa une
partie est sous protectorat néo
zélandais et l'autre sous celui les
états unis le paysage en est à nîmes
m
william morris est à l'américain de 70
ans il est arrivé à un bonjour ma pago
pago sur un radeau de fabrication
prénommé les sept petites serres il a
battu en longueur de distance je
continue il est parti de la côte ouest
des usa est maintenant de nice attend
qu'on veuille bien rapatrie les cases
dès sa mort en sont conçus d'une manière
commode
elle permet une aération parfait il
suffit simplement de lever les nombreux
store de bambou léger qui en font les
mulets ici aux samoa
alain gerbault venait se délasser comme
les fleurs aux couleurs innombrables
devant chaque case c'est une symphonie
de pétales multicolores et chaque matin
les jeunes filles vienne décorée de
fleurs fraîches la maison des palabres
qui existent dans chaque village la
maison des palabres est le lieu de
rencontre où les anciens viennent
bavarder
il s'en entretenir les derniers potins
ou des solutions à trouver
voici les orchidées elles poussent
librement merveilleux n'est ce pas
m
et d'un bon dans l'espace en nouvelle
calédonie à nouméa dont une sur belon la
capitale pour nous rendre en direction
du phare amédée voilà séparer de la côte
par une dizaine de kilos il fut
construit par napoléon iii
ces tâches que vous apercevez ce sont
des tapis de coraux les tâches un petit
peu plus sombre dans le emboîtement
admirez la barre
l'hymne aux canards
îlot de fraîcheur au milieu des marines
mais l'intérieur de cette île qui a la
forme d'un long cigare de 400 km sur 50
de large vous surprend parfois par des
paysages qui pourraient être ceux de la
france
et alors là vous allez vous divertir car
pour traverser les fleuves calédonien on
se sert souvent d'un bac dont le
fonctionnement
jugez vous même ce sont des kanaks qui
vous conduisent rapidement en quelques
minutes à rythme régulier
d'un côté de la rive à l'autre ces
moyens archaïques thorn pas disparaître
paraît-il car chaque année de nouveaux
ponts les remplace la nouvelle calédonie
se place seconde dans la liste des
principaux producteurs de nickel
venant tout de suite après le canada le
résultat en est qu'au dernier
recensement
on compte une voiture pour quatre
habitants exactement comme aux états
unis
sur la côte ouest bourail on est un des
plus jolis endroits la roche percée et
le vent tel le bonhomme
m
les sculptures ornent des portes et sont
la fierté de toute la tribu sculpture
extraordinaire du reste je pression
mystérieuse
encore plus haut il ya les roches noires
de guéguen dont certaines ont un curieux
profil je dirais devront pas une poule
qui couve attendait un petit peu voilà
de plus loin on se rend mieux compte
et voilà on longe la plage à la
recherche de certains trous creusés à la
surface du sable ceux-ci décèle à coup
sûr la présence d' inscrire au fish
mais lorsqu'on marche le long de ses
récifs si l'on explore attentivement
chaque mètre carré
on est surpris d'y découvrir tout un
monde étrange et stupéfiants un monde
qui semble mort mais qui vit c'est le
récit vivant voici tout d'abord les
jours saints crayon puis l'ours à
châtaignes étoiles jaunes sur fond en
mots
étrange petits animaux fragiles c'est le
may hamm a atteint
il y aura de toutes les couleurs le plus
commun et celle que l'on appelle les
dollars parce qu'elle est verte
voici les porcelaines il existe de
nombreuses espèces de porcelaine ou
grains de café tout coloré brillante et
plus belles les unes que les autres
remarquables par leur coquille lice à
l'extérieur ce qui signifie que le
calcaire est déposée par le manteau de
chair en petites quantités
irrégulièrement et pour cela il faut
bien entendu la joie des collectionneurs
petit pont en fait les colliers est
grande on les coupe en deux pour en
faire des rap est très souvent en
soulevant de grosses pierres ou des
morceaux de corail mort du lagon on peut
voir ce curieux animal à 5 bras longs
délié mobile perry c'est le petit
piquant également mobile
il avance il glisse s'il se hisse enfin
il avance chaque jour à marée basse le
récif laisse apparaître son jardin de
corail et de marins morts
nous
et la perle la plus sûre en est la rose
de mer en fait drôle de mer c'est plutôt
une orchidée mais cette merveille de la
nature est extrêmement rare et très très
difficile à trouver il faut quelquefois
des mois pour en découvrir
le bénitier vite également dans les
récifs de corail la double coquille
ondulé abrite un animal dont le
bourrelet signe du manteau et colorée de
vert de bleu intense de ma rouen de gris
ou de rose une chose également
surprenante c'est la quantité incroyable
des toiles de mer dans la marche lente
et pourtant plus rapide que celle de
l'escargot quand on les regarde de près
on ne sait pas ce qu'il faut admirer le
mieux son élégante forme ou sa
décoration
nous
moi
et voici le coup ça dure qu'un on dirait
un petit peu le tueur va mao
de son vrai nom c'est une autre espèce
des toiles de mer de forme pentagonale
pouvant être gris jaune verdâtre brun ou
rouge
ça pourrit rugueuse et maintenant c'est
une autre histoire
nous sommes toi moutou ou allons bassin
d'une cinquantaine de mètres sur 10 ou
15 de large contient 5 requins plus une
tortue qui vivent en toute tranquillité
et voilà le plus extraordinaire un petit
garçon plonge à l'eau attrape le requin
par la queue et joue avec il n'arrive
jamais l'accident le petit garçon n'est
pas un spécialiste c'est un petit garçon
comme beaucoup d'autres il s'agit
simplement de prendre le requin pour
cheval ont eu socke sur le dos et on
parcourt le bassin dans toute sa
longueur
et puis on change de requins au mont
changerait de monture ne sont pas
méchantes sait pas très bien avec elle
des deux s'amuse le plus
peut-être les deux près tout
à
et tous les petits enfants là bas sont
capables de faire du rodéo sur hrk à
tous les deux sont extrêmement
décontractés plus vous même
voilà deux tiers par là que tu ne
manques pas parce que tu es gentil
dès leur plus jeune âge les paumotu
s'entraîne à côtoyer les requins il
commence très tôt avec des squales
pratiquement inoffensif comme ceux ci et
s'habituer ainsi petit à petit à se
baigner d'abord dans le lagon ensuite
dans les passes ou dans le bleu et ce
jour là le jour où il se baigneront dans
le bleu ce seront des hommes car les
requins qu'ils y rencontrent n'aiment
pas beaucoup qu'on leur tire l'accueil
nippon monte à califourchon sur leur dos
mais ceci est une autre histoire